muy buenas noches estamos de regreso
para conocer las principales noticias en
materia económica de américa latina y
del resto del mundo junto a nuestra
compañera daniela hablando daniela vamos
a empezar en españa' que está planteando
subir impuestos a las grandes fortunas
verdad si santiago muy buenas noches
pues el plan de gastos recordar para el
próximo año incluye un alza de impuestos
a las grandes fortunas una iniciativa
que ya han analizado algunos países de
américa latina como chile y argentina
pero que no ha prosperado todavía más
temprano conversamos con nuestra
corresponsal en españa rosa pérez quien
nos cuenta a continuación
el gobierno español ha presentado hoy el
anteproyecto de ley para los
presupuestos de 2021 una presentación
llevada a cabo por el presidente del
gobierno pedro sánchez y por el
vicepresidente pablo iglesias y de este
modo han escenificado el acuerdo
alcanzado por la coalición en el
ejecutivo entre el partido socialista y
el partido unidas podemos unos sobre
presupuestos que tal y como ha recalcado
el gobierno baten un récord en términos
de inversiones social ya que se cuenta
con una partida de unos 240 mil millones
de euros entre los cuales se cuenta ya
con el dinero que llegará de bruselas
para los fondos de recuperación europeos
por otro lado estos presupuestos también
contemplan una subida de los impuestos a
las rentas más altas sin embargo esta
subida no afectará ni tan sólo al 1% de
la población y el gobierno ha querido
destacar la diferencia con la que sea
frente a esta crisis económica con una
economía expansiva en relación a las
políticas de austeridad con la que se
afrontó la crisis financiera de 2008 eso
sí cabe destacar que la prueba de fuego
para estos presupuestos
para la continuidad de la legislatura
será cuando tengan que ser votados en el
congreso a mediados de noviembre y es
que recordemos fue la imposibilidad de
alcanzar una mayoría para aprobar los
presupuestos en 2019 lo que llevó a
pedro sánchez a convocar elecciones ese
mismo año después de la moción de
censura de mariano rajoy en 2018 unas
elecciones que fueron repetidas y tras
las cuales surgió la edición en el
ejecutivo actual
bueno danny de europa américa latina
porque el kobe 19 por supuesto afecto o
no lo que es la inversión extranjera en
los países de la región y santiago en
los primeros 6 meses de 2019 los países
de américa latina' recibieron
inversiones por 83 mil millones de
dólares pero la crisis por el
coronavirus bajó la cifra en una cuarta
parte la buena noticia para la región es
que el desplome es más bajo que el
promedio mundial que es del 48% si
observamos la gráfica por países de
santiago si hay unos que sobrepasan ese
promedio en perú por ejemplo la
inversión foránea se desplomó en un 72%
entre enero y junio debido a la
suspensión de proyectos mineros en
brasil por su parte cayó un 48 por
ciento en chile lo hizo un 68 por ciento
y le sigue en argentina y colombia con
el 40 por ciento y el 34 respectivamente
bueno no sé si le interesará a todos
pero por lo menos quizás alguna parte de
la audiencia porque se está despejando
el camino para una millonaria
adquisición en el sector de lujo de qué
se trata estamos hablando de louis
vuitton que busca adquirir a la joyería
tiffany's el primero es francés
y el segundo es estadounidense de
santiago estos dos gigantes de lujo
están en una disputa jurídica porque
louis vuitton había dicho que no iba a
poder completar la compra del 24 de
noviembre que era la fecha límite entre
otras cosas dijo que el desempeño de
tiffany's había sido pésimo durante la
pandemia pues schifani les respondió y
le dijo no señor el acuerdo tiene que
salir adelante y llegó el caso a un
tribunal en delaware fuentes citadas por
la agencia reuters dijeron que la
negociación podría estar a punto de
resucitar luego de que la comisión
europea diera este martes su visto bueno
para la operación y lo haría a un precio
incluso menor ya no de 16 mil 200
millones de dólares sino 15.800
continuamos con los indicadores de la
jornada wall street' del cerro mixto
luego de que la casa blanca viera
escasas posibilidades de un plan de
alivio antes de elecciones en europa las
pérdidas también se atribuyen a los
nervios propios de los días previos a
los comicios en este país
en américa latina' segundo desplome
consecutivo en buenos aires en apenas
dos días ha perdido más del 10% serrano
como siempre con la pérdida cifra del
día 35 mil millones de botellas de vino
santiago esa la cifra del día en la
producción mundial esperada este año una
cifra que se ubica por debajo del
promedio de los últimos cinco años así
parezca mucha esto según la organización
internacional de la viña y el vino el
desplome en ventas afectó a los
principales productores que son italia
francia y españa tenía muchísimas
gracias por esta la completísima crónica
económica regresamos en breve con
muchísimas más noticias sigan en france
[Música]